Margot Lee Shetterly:Hello, my name isMargot
Lee Shetterlyand I am the author ofHIDDEN
FIGURES. Film Courage: How long did it take
to write and then sell the book? Margot Lee
Shetterly:All told it took about six years.
A little less than six years, actually. I
started working on it in December of 2010.
I really did about three years of research
before I put together a book proposal, finding
an agent and then finding a publisher. So
I submitted the final draft of this book in
July of this year. And the book was published
in September, a couple months before the movie
came out. Film Courage: So then how did the
movie come about? How was it discovered and
who wanted to take it on? I know Theodore
Melfi [and Allison Schroeder] did the screenplay
(the adaptation). Margot Lee Shetterly:My
literary agent isMackenzie Brady Watsonand
some how it landed on the desk ofDonna Gigliottiwho
is the producer of the movie. So Donna called
me up and remember this was only a book proposal
this time. It was like three years ago and
I hadn’t finished the book. She saw the
book proposal and she said“We are going
to make a movie of this story.”And I thought
“Well, geez. I’m still writing the book.
It’s not even a book. You want to option
my book proposal? I’d never written a book
before.” But she believe in that story.
She really took a flyer on a first time writer/author
and now the rest is history. Everything that
she said on this first phone call has come
true. Film Courage: I know HIDDEN FIGURES
is a true story that many did not know of
before it came out. What movie did you see
which had the same type of impact that I’m
sure many people will feel once they see the
film [HIDDEN FIGURES]? Margot Lee Shetterly:Wow!
That’s a hard question. There are so many
movies that are amazing and inspirational.
You kind of put me on the spot here. Film
Courage: [Laughs] Sorry! Margot Lee Shetterly:You
know, I’d have to think about it. In general
the thing about HIDDEN FIGURES, even though
it is a work of non-fiction, it is totally
a work of imagination, you know? And I think
the thing about movies that you do remember
and that do inspire you is that they do spark
your imagination and I think that is the reason
people are responding so strongly is that
they see something in these women that says
to them “Wow! I just expanded my imagination
of what the world looks like and who I might
be.” Film Courage: And you would hear them
[the women working at NASA] speaking to you,
in your own way? In your research that you
did on them….did you hear their voices?
Margot Lee Shetterly:I did! It’s so funny
that you asked that question. I found myself
talking to them, having conversations with
them and dreaming about them, and thinking
about them. I looked at photos of them to
see what they looked like at different parts
of their life. I listened to their children
talk about the gestures. Like Dorothy Vaughan.
When she got upset would start putting her
finger on the table and everybody knew to
back off, you know? And that she was really,
like a fearless kind of a woman. I knew all
of these different things about them until
I felt that they had really come back to life
and that they were my friends. And they really
were. They become my companions. Of course
in the case of Katherine Johnson, she is 98-years-old
and she is very much still with us. And I
had an incredible privilege to spend time
interviewing her and getting to know her life
firsthand. Film Courage: Excellent! Thank
you! Best of luck and you look beautiful!
Margot Lee Shetterly:Thank you!